[Music]
with Brenton Athenee committing to
change my team move forward getting rid
of all the dust and cobwebs we furnished
all the rooms with brand-new bedding but
the biggest change was overhauling the
ice-cream parlour offer yo ladies
welcome this is what I call a parlour
you had a dreadful space here yes oh my
god now it's turned into something
magical
do you think there's any chance that I
can get a sample we will be throwing
samples outs everywhere this is way
beyond our expectation
[Music]
given the importance of the local
wineries I brought in sommelier de force
how are you who repaired the bad
reputations with the locals that Brendon
athle had you're gonna need to nurture
those relationships and he created a
brand new menu featuring all washington
wine you're no longer gonna have to say
sayonara how many luck wise finally to
company all this I created a small more
exciting menu that features all fresh
food dig in
have a little taste everything fresh
better what I have learned from this
community is that local support is
everything and this town is willing to
give Brent an athlete a second chance hi
everybody how are you today good to see
you guys would you like to see my new
ice cream parlor here with all the new
improvements I'm hoping Brendon Daphne
make a good impression for the people of
Shilla the hotel is booked up and the
guests will sleep well tonight in the
brand new bedding we've added to all the
rooms there's a real buzz about the new
menu and the kitchen is easily executing
the dishes a quiche a chicken sandwich
and I got the salmon what we're trying
to do is just focus - with the help of
similar day Foss the customers are
pleased with a local selection of wines
they're offering at BC McDonald's you
like that
I'm always making a mess that's the idea
I'm the official scooper the ice cream
shop is a hit and brent is eating happy
giving away samples if you drop it on
the floor you own it right with
everything a success I'm hoping Brent
makes one important rule change with
these hotel have you thought about what
I mentioned about the children regarding
children in the hotel are you still
sticking with my children you know what
I'm gonna stick to the adults waffle I
don't only why well look at you take two
or three or four children up there and
I'm gonna tell you they wipe out the
whole damn place what the noise noise
crying whatever gum pop and God forbid I
samples of ice cream they will have a
young daughter I know I'm talking three
four eight-year-old have you asked
yourself the constant you know am I
missing on turnover revenue we may miss
a few but I think we miss a few on the
other end if they were two or three kids
running down the hall but not everything
every kid is this is that no easy I mean
just trying to be open with maybe a
couple of routes I will give it five
that's a tough one
I'm disappointed Bren won't alter his
rules about allowing kids at the hotel
but hopefully after seen the success of
the relaunch he'll change his mind